A plot twist is an effective way of keeping
audiences on the edge of their seats, but
not every surprise comes completely out of
the blue.
Filmmakers just can’t help leaving a hint
or two for all to see – even if it’s just
the viewers paying the closest attention who
catch them.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Best Movie Clues
You Missed.
Back to the Future – Twin Pines Mall
The first Back to the Future ends with a bit
of a twist, revealing that the life Marty
McFly leaves behind in 1985 is not the same
he returns to.
His actions in the past have caused his entire
family history to change for the better - but
you don’t have to wait until the final sequence
for that surprise.
When Marty rushes to the parking lot of Twin
Pines Mall to save Doc before he’s killed,
it’s revealed to have changed its name to
Lone Pine Mall, a result of Marty running
over one of Farmer Peabody’s prized pines
when he first arrived in 1955, and the first
clue that he altered the timeline, instead
of preserving it.
21 Jump Street – A Familiar Flavor
Undercover officers Schmidt and Jenko are
given a simple mission: infiltrate and bring
down a high school designer drug ring.
Finding the dealer is simple enough, but finding
his supplier and kingpin proves more challenging.
But it didn’t have to be.
After the two first take the drug while at
school, Jenko notes that “it tastes like
cool ranch”.
Just a few moments later, Coach Walters appears
snacking on – you guessed it - Cool Ranch
Doritos.
Walters is revealed to be the operation’s
mastermind, explaining where that flavor came
from.
The officers may have spotted the clue, if
they weren’t too distracted by their own
tongues.
Reservoir Dogs – Big Tippers
After a jewel heist goes horribly wrong, Quentin
Tarantino’s cast of thieves are convinced
that there’s a rat in their midst, with
the survivors left to find out which one of
their team may be working with the police.
A collection of bottles hints that Mr. Orange
isn’t on the same side as Mr. White or Pink,
but the undercover LAPD officer actually lets
his secret slip in the very first scene.
First, he changes his mind to fit in with
his colleague.
Then when the group is asked who didn’t
tip for their breakfast, Orange immediately
squeals, showing he doesn’t subscribe to
the same code as his partners.
If only they’d caught it, the movie’s
ending might have been a lot less messy.
Fight Club – Flashes of Tyler
When the Narrator learns that he and Tyler
Durden are actually the same person, it blows
his mind - but eagle eyed viewers weren’t
caught completely by surprise.
In the film’s first act, the Narrator begins
to see quick glimpses of Tyler as he battles
his insomnia, suggesting he’s simply a figment
of his imagination begging to be unleashed.
If that wasn’t enough, Tyler later calls
the Narrator on a pay phone that doesn’t
accept incoming calls.
Saving the big twist from eagle-eyed viewers
was obviously not a priority for director
David Fincher.
“He is Jack’s Spoiler Alert.”
The Sixth Sense – An Unfriendly Ghost
Discovering that Bruce Willis’s character
was dead the whole time is one of the greatest
twists in cinematic history, immediately warranting
a second viewing, where viewers learn the
twist wasn’t necessarily a total surprise.
It makes sense for Crowe to spend plenty of
time with his patient Cole, but it is a little
strange that he doesn’t address any other
human after the opening scene, at one point
arriving late for an anniversary dinner, with
his wife not even acknowledging his presence.
The clues are subtle enough to go unnoticed
the first time, but on repeat viewings, they’re
impossible to miss.
Shutter Island – A Glass Half Full
The movie’s story of a Federal Marshall
pursuing a killer in a remote mental hospital
is turned on its head in Shutter Island, when
hero Teddy Daniels is revealed to be a patient
acting out an elaborate fantasy.
It’s a shocking twist, but viewers should
have known that Teddy’s experience was less
than reliable.
When a patient requests a drink during her
interview, the glass she drinks from is non-existent,
returning only when it has been completely
drained.
Teddy’s fear of water may be actively censoring
what he does, and doesn’t see, but regardless,
it’s just one of the clues that show the
investigation is not what it seems.
The Usual Suspects – The Truth is Golden
Everyone was floored to learn the unassuming
Verbal Kint was really the criminal mastermind
Keyser Soze, but hints were sprinkled throughout
this mysterious crime drama.
In the film’s opening scene, the faceless
Keyser lights a cigarette with a gold lighter
before setting a fiery blaze.
Later on when Verbal leaves the police station,
one of his belongings is a gold cigarette
lighter - the same one used in that first
sequence.
It’s a minor detail before the far larger
twists are revealed, meaning deductive viewers
realized the truth before the characters in
the story.
The Big Lebowski – No Strike, He’s Out
Since the film’s starring duo spends most
of their time dismissing their fellow bowler,
Donnie, viewers might not notice that every
time he’s shown bowling, he gets a strike
– until his final game.
He seems as confused as anyone when he leaves
pins standing, but exits the bowling alley
to face off against a group of violent nihilists,
where he succumbs to a heart attack and dies.
Turns out, his last bowl was an ominous piece
of foreshadowing.
What would have happened if he’d thrown
a gutter ball?
The Prestige – Look to The Birds
A single trick lies at the heart of this tale
of rival magicians, with Hugh Jackman’s
character desperately trying to learn how
Christian Bale’s Borden can transport between
two points instantly.
He eventually recreates the trick by copying
himself, drowning each time as his new copy
appears to wow audiences.
In the end, Borden’s explanation is a twin
brother, not actual magic – a secret discovered
early on by a young boy unconvinced by a ‘disappearing
bird’ trick.
The boy sees what the audience doesn’t,
but even his rival’s horrifying loop of
suicide is explained using the same dead bird.
The Dark Knight Rises - The League’s Mark
The third of Christopher Nolan’s Batman
films finds Bruce Wayne surprised and devastated,
discovering his corporate ally and lover “Miranda
Tate” is actually Talia al Ghul, daughter
of Batman Begins villain Ra’s al Ghul.
But her membership in the League of Shadows
is foreshadowed long before she confesses
it.
Bruce makes a note of a triangular scar on
her back which is never explained, but are
similar to those covering Bane’s head, implying
a link between the two.
Some have argued that the scar resembles the
brand of the League seen in Batman Begins,
but whatever the case, having a villain covered
in scars suggested there was more to “Miranda”
than met the eye.
Those are our picks for great clues hidden
in the background of movies.
Are there any we missed?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one!